给大家分享一招,休一招,就能解决你拍个短日频,做直播,90%的问题,这是9万,我自己就是这么做的,就拍了很多包括,怎么做呢?特别简单,就直接上,你手机里边一定有那个路隐金,对吧,路隐地,然后呢,你只要有想法,你就直接入音就好了,哪天就拍路隐,比如说啊,比如说
哎,我前两天我看了一个文案,哎呀,我就得记得特别好,这个文案是怎么说呢?
说你啊,在这个风约长也努力也辛苦啊,你正好很多钱,最终可以修身的时候,你不但没修身,你跑到去争花虧车了。你看,我就看到这种好文案,你修上看到的文案比较好的,你就随时把它记得下来。
然后呢,你觉得哪个好,不好,你可以把它杀了,好的话呢,你可以通过这个AI啊,就把它说得成文字,就记得你就需要哭了,那你以后你不是不是就很多很多的这个直点,注意啊,这个不是中点啊,那个我原来啊,在写家的心法的时候,有一张我自己写特别得意,叫什么呢,叫每天写点什么?
这个这一张哦,咱们夫妇改了俗吧,就以前叫什么叫如何写错,我原来那个名字叫如何写错,但是后来我改成每天写点什么以后特别得意,为什么,差别就是每天写点什么和写错的差别,我又说写错完了,就很准担心的很多人,哎呀,哦,我不会写错呀,这就不敢动手,你要说写点什么,随便写,只要写了就算,你会发现就将军的文靠,就很准就要你做的,做的做的做的,还真能写出好东西呢,
这个路音笔啊,路音笔这个路音这个事儿啊,我个人人为凭每天写点什么,但成本还得你想在这路,看来不是好书啊,看来又有一个好的灵感啊,对吧,一个好的端子啊,你把它的记住一下,是不是成本到底,好,各位,这个不是中点,中点是,今天我们已经生活在短视频使他了,所以个养成一个更好的习惯,就不是路音,而是如相,直接拍自己,直接拍本,注意,
当我们一说拍的软片,那时候你就说一定要发表出来,注意,这是一种基督的方法,他可不是为了拍点音笔,拍的软片,不是为了发表的,就是基督,就和那个路音一样,哎,我入展了,我可怕可不凡,对,我就把它当过一个,我自己基督的方式,你比如说啊,我觉得,为什么很人拍不了软片,就是后面样子,后面样子,就怕这个直到,怕那个看到,所以呢,我觉得那个人说的特别好,
你问得来讲,创业也好,拍短视频,你就要不要脸,但是不要脸,这个才是,但是太难听了,但是那天呢,我就看来一个人说的特别好,就特别好的,说呀,不要脸,从哲学的角度上讲,就入我,我,我看完这个段子,我就觉得太棒,你就知道吗,就就你看,你每次拿下来说,你不是说,我不要脸,而是说,我要我,哎,这感觉特别好,你看,
这个度了的那个段子,这个不一定反而去,你就是一看,好,我就反而就不好,我就放了那边,那边,当然比起,对不对,然后又有灵港了,我再有一个比起,我谁说随地拿下来就,就拍,对,你只要没有发出去的这个,这个动作,其实你是极度放走的,然后呢,再来一个啊,反而我平时就这样,我就说你看啊,我认为为什么很人,就拍不了软片,你,一个很转的原因,这也是比,就是你要说你话话,
你会发现多个话吧
话给云话给放个多个话
然后你说咱们开始话话吧
完了
他不会了
为什么呢
因为在他他呀
话话的事
他就一定要话的特别好
因为他话的不是特别好
他就不敢话
因为他不敢话
所以他永远不会话话
所以最好的方法就是
你就是话个发话给云
那么对他清楚就可以了
你先话
等你话上话的话你就话好了
你看我看
讲讲我在独映里面
刷到一个
要昏思多
你看他就会用前面话讲
讲的就是这样的特别好
你说他话的话
就就偏那个书家话的话吧
不是吧
但是他就把他结合在一宫
他会就活了吧
所以我觉得
这个
他一短视频
他也是一样的
对
你要说
我就完美
我叫派他向张毅某一样
哎呀
我就云王家外一样
那你放心吧
这个什么拍不着了
他十天逼不出一条来
但是有接时候
我认为派短的频率
像我就打了一堵
我原来你看我拍第一条视频的时候
我觉得派的特别的有意思
我真的没多想
我就上来拍
但我说以后从这开始拍了
因为那一条
我就开始一直拍了
一直是拍了
哪个人就开始开始堵了
我当时真没想到我要拍的多好
我只是说把一个话
把它说出来把它说清楚
然后越拍越好越拍越好
就像假张和这个电影一样
你看
很同时很喜事
但是特别的抓人
所以我觉得真实这个东西
才是最有力量的
真实这个东西
吐到急子
那就是艺术
随时有什么想法
对我的派许了
有灵打了派的派的派
好玩容易派的派
搞笑的东西派的派
这个话没有好看
派的派的派
你就是
没事把它做个记录
我还真不是发出去
这样有个什么好处的
你派的多了以后
你脱引了
对你面对进口你不进场
我就拍的嘛
我已经讲了习惯了
好玩容易随时就能够打了
因为你讲了
下一次习惯了
好玩容易拍了
好的端子拍回来
然后你会发现
不是所有的东西都很好
但是你会在
这个很好
这个东西对别人用
哎呀
我告诉你
我是怎么这样
是没
那我自己对你干什么
把它放上去
哎呀
这个东西
特别有因素
你们可以看到我的方式去
你就说不定每条就活
我自己好多视频
我跟一讲
都是无以声
男孩就开始排行刚才一样
排排行一会
讲一段就就发现了
然后结果就包括了
这肯单没什么结果
我什么准备啊
什么灯光
没有
那很能说
可是我怎么拍
没理由量呢
我跟一讲的故事就明白了
你们知道那个
标我们投标
那个标
八万墙上
投标
好
墙上放个标
然后呢
我给你几个标
几个小时代
给你足够的时间标
你标
你要你党你准备没有
你党二个几分钟
你觉得你比较好了
大声说一句
给你个小时
你在你能投忠多少
还有一个方法
换了点
有个标
无用特别标
我跟你苗
你的水平
你苗太长时间也没打用
对吧
有问题可以回家
你拍下要时间也没打用
拿那个标
差不多
不认吗
让所谓点
骗了
我用一点
放上一点
放下一点
我钱一点
我后一点
这一点
那一点
投一条事
同样投一个条事
你告诉我
谁
众打的可能性高
千分之九百九十九子代劳
一定是后半个
对不对
那那那那那那那那我没有那么多丢
你拍下多少视频
有啥成本
这盘盘
那盘盘
这好看
那好看
有啥成本啊
对不对
那那那那那那你前准的成功律高
后准的成功律低
那你要怎么办起啊
我告诉你
我把那个
扎到强设的
只要没在把那标我钱都把他把下的
甚至这个这个标把上外还我的把下
我只留内还的
然后你告诉我
谁的成功律高
你可能跟我说
你这不是作弊吧
你这不是把人来吗
作弊吗
你去看一看
任何一个人
只要这个人成功了
你看这麽问的是什么
你是怎麽成功的
有多少人关心
他为了做电视副刷断努力
他失败了多少次
任民指关心你最后不再打上
留了多少指标